i had the fantastic opportunity of going
to egypt last month
and in that time i was able to go inside
the second pyramid of giza
on two separate occasions and my second
pyramid i'm referring to
kafri's pyramid but let's be real it was
not his pyramid
and i'm about to show you nearly 16
minutes of raw unedited video of my tour
inside and out of this incredible
structure and then you can look and
think for yourself as to whether you
believe that its original purpose
was to be a tomb for the pharaohs now
let me also just say that i've been
enjoying sharing my raw
video footage from my cell phone with
you guys have already shared the great
pyramid
the bent pyramid i'll also be showing
you inside the dendera complex including
hidden chambers there
and also forbidden video inside the
osiris shaft
nearly 28 minutes which i was not
supposed to film guys
but i also know that many of you are
excited for me to get back to my typical
type presentation where i show you
slides and pictures
so thankfully i have tens of thousands
of photos that i took with my new
mirrorless camera and they are of
outstanding quality but i've been in the
process of an out-of-state move so
give me some time to piece those
together as i've been consumed with life
but look forward to these other videos
in the interim and though
yeah okay i admit i did shoot in
vertical most the time
whoops forgive me but hey it is still 4k
video
and at least it shows you a perspective
that you can't possibly have by seeing
pictures and video presentation or
slides like i typically show you
so look forward to these other videos in
the interim but i look forward to making
my other type videos real soon
but without further ado here's nearly 16
minutes of that
the first video clip is of my second
visit there
and then the other video clips were from
my first visit in there just to kind of
paint you a different picture on how
that went down but
without further ado here we go
all bedrock
second pyramid
i'm 5 foot 10 for comparison
[Music]
5 foot 10 about six feet high or so
[Music]
this is the so-called queen's chamber
all bedrock subterranean i'm on the
impression that the walls are
approximately 30 feet or so high
again all in bedrock
going down now back up
more leg day
yeah i'll give you some money
[Music]
uh
um
i think they're on the bus
thank you
i'm not that pyramid
has to be the most impressive i believe
this after this trip i believe this
pyramid came first
before the great pyramid for a number of
reasons
which i'll share in a video but i want
the tour of this
this is being shot iphone 12 pro
and i have an ultra wide angle 0.5 right
now to anyone curious
obviously i've been speed walking the
whole time
[Music]
i don't want to stop recording just
letting clear a little bit of distance
before i
trek up don't want to stop recording
how's my hair look
how tall are you man six feet right
it's good for comparison all right away
i go
[ __ ] i just okay
i'll live you gotta stay if you heard
that that was my
back
i wouldn't be surprised if i tore my
shirt that was
that was a good guess all worth it
this video just doesn't do justice to
the size of the tunnel though
i'm halfway over i mean look at me now
i'm leaving
my ladies
[Music]
that is a quarry
i'll just have to put all my thoughts
into a video not a tomb
nope not a tune
at least i don't think so
it's almost hard to have the words
because
not because i'm out of breath because
i'm apparently out of shape
there's a workout going in there
goes down all into bedrock back up not
much higher than we are now
off of that room
i hope you guys enjoyed this i know i
did how's my back look
after i took is it bleeding through
how does it look i'll be all right
what do you think ben it was a magical
experience
you bet disneyland yeah
don't go to ancient rome people don't go
to don't go greece come to egypt
this place is just y'all missing out the
size of everything
is epic it is
i was saying like again i'm talking to
the camera i don't have the words it's
hard to know what to describe going in
there i'm like
i don't get a tomb vibe at all it's like
you go up here like oh yeah tombs the
pyramids were tombs
for the pharaohs and hide all their
stuff in there i'm like you just go
straight down straight up
what what maze is there yeah that one
little door thing like that's it
yeah ah there's the so-called great
oh no is the great pyramid but um
not much it's bigger than the second was
it 30 feet different
yeah it's not alive
no thank you chokron hi you remember me
that's it say hi to camera very good
welcome to egypt american forever
yes yes come to egypt hi ladies
no no no no no no no i appreciate it
i do not but i thank you chokron
they put in your they put in your hands
that way you'll have to give them money
they do it to everyone dodge it
hello hello
almost tripped again i've almost fallen
and tripped uh
something like 341 times on this trip
haven't been down once
almost rolled my ankle about another
hundred times
haven't rolled it once famous last words
i'm just still recording i don't even
know what to say but this is fun i guess
i'll post this to instagram or something
yeah look at all these stones
hi lord one of those
that's our bus over there
hey ben fill my back real quick is it uh
is it torn or is it white is it anything
you're fine no mark at all oh there's a
little like a little wet mark there
maybe
it's probably blood what's that from
just stabbing my back in the tunnel for
fun
all right everyone talk to you later
is
with
[Music]
i can feel my hair touch the roof of
this so it's basically
about six feet roughly maybe five eleven
because i'm right at the top almost
so look how small that door looks
compared to the hole
all bedrock except for the ceiling as
you just heard
there's a step
[Music]
is it okay if i step on this
[Music]
and is this built so this was placed in
here that's sitting on that
yes this is
and they are usually
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
uh
then
[Music]
so this goes down that goes to the other
second entrance or exit
higher up all of this is carved out of
solid bedrock
solid
[Music]
yeah the pyramid has uh air conditioner
so the ancients were advanced
as you can tell that's a solid
now this is small this is very small
as you can see these steps were added in
otherwise it would just be flush bedruck
this is about three feet or so high so
i'm scrapped i'm crouched down
it's uncomfortable
and then it opens
it opens up and now it's i'm 5'10
and it's got a few inches on me
this goes down to subterranean well what
they call the queen's chamber
[Music]
but it's as you can see locked
that goes up probably
10 feet 11 feet just to guess
so we went down and now we go back up
and that's the exit
but that's at ground level and so that
is a
i think it's a 26 degree angle if you
remember right at least that's what it
is in the great pyramid
oh yeah oh you guys waiting on me yeah
no perfect here we go
leading the way i hope my narration
isn't
annoying if i post this on instagram you
guys can forgive me but
like a freaking christmas wow okay so
even my back just hit the
the roof like this is much smaller than
the camera's showing
this is shot on an iphone 12 pro
wide angle it's on set on ultrawide 0.5
x
right now just for frame a reference to
anyone that wants to know
and now we're entering outside
okay oh thank you
that was i'll never forget that thank
you
yes please